[Music]
[Applause]
so if you saw my video on Richard Ryder
you recall that after the events of nova
volume 1 that richard Ryder had
reappeared and the Mighty Thor issue
number 412 as a member of a new group
called the new Warriors and the new
warriors was a group that had been
assembled by the superhero Knight
Thrasher and the whole basis for knife
Thrasher assembling the new Warriors was
due to the fact that his parents had
previously been murdered and as a result
he really kind of took on this Batman s
persona in the sense that he was a owner
of a charitable organization by day but
he was a crime fighter by night but as
time progressed and he began to realize
the sheer magnitude of some of the
powers belonging to various
supervillains and the sheer number of
supervillains he began to find himself
outclassed and so as a result he created
a team that could assist him in
achieving his goals of fighting crime
now over the publication history of the
New Warriors we see several roster
changes taking place which also include
Nova leading the group due to the
annihilation storyline and what we see
is that nine Thrasher who had previously
been covering the financial costs of the
team in order to in order for them to
maintain their operations is beginning
to lose money and so he signs the team
up for a reality TV show and the whole
basis of this reality TV show is that
the new Warriors will go about their
day-to-day actions of fighting crime but
they will do it in front of a camera and
the network will cover the cost of their
operations but what we see is that
ultimately the new Warriors come across
a set of super villains who have a lot
more power than they had initially
thought we see every member except for
the except for one member of the new New
Warriors dying and we ultimately see the
Marvel Civil War storyline kick off
after a massive amount of destruction is
caused due to the actions of one of the
super villains
[Music]